talk to me about your party this morning
personally holding the Prime Minister
responsible for what you've described as
a 1.05 billion pound Tory mortgage
penalty surely that had something to do
with Liz truss well it did have
something to do with Liz trust but as
after the question people have to ask
themselves is who's better off after 13
years of conservative government and
it's certainly not people who have
mortgages because what we can look at
today is the impact of that Kamikaze
budget there are a million people who've
had to remortgage since that budget
there's another million households who
are invariable mortgages and we can
calculate the additional cost on average
people are paying 3 000 pounds a year
more in interest and I know the UK is a
problem all over the world but the
specific circumstances of that Kamikaze
budget and the recklessness that they
went about that the lack of property
transparency not doing things in the
proper way just not listening to the
evidence they should be held accountable
to that and I know there are people who
will say look that was listrus that was
one part of the conservative party it's
not the people in charge now they've all
got to take responsibility yeah but you
guys wanted massive wage Rises for
public sector workers which would have
fueled further inflation which would
have meant that we would see interest
rates go up I know that will be the
conservative case we have been very
disciplined in asking for first of all
negotiations to take place with
workforces recognizing the difficulty
that they have been under in certainly
many public service areas for the last
13 years but let's be clear many this is
not the 1970s many of these public
sector workers were not asking for
inflation Plus
a certain percentage they were asking
for the recognition from government
they'd had a very difficult decade that
they were struggling with the cost of
living and they were major recruitment
problems in many parts of the public
services so I do not accept that what
we've been putting forward is a is an
inflationary prospectus you've got to
recognize the burden the public sector
workers have been under but
fundamentally the the question here is
about how not just the Liz trust
government brief as it was has led to
this it's the whole 13 years which have
been very low growth very high taxes as
a result for poor public services and
every conservative MP has been a part of
that and will hold them to account for
that record and um how do you feel about
sitting around the cabinet table with
lib Dems I think following the results
of last Thursday we can say with some
confidence that we can campaign for a
majority labor government well because
in the key Battlegrounds last week we
saw labor vastly exceed the conservative
party in terms of the votes we received
from the public and when you then have a
national election London and Scotland
and Wales I think we can have confidence
in saying to people if you want a labor
government if you want to get rid of
this conservative government vote labor
for a positive transformational change
and I I don't see anything out power
sharing them well I think we can say to
the public you decide the election and
that's got to be the right way it's not
for politicians to say we think it's
going to be like this just quite get
over the line would you do a deal the
boss says short labor for a labor
government that's the message we can go
out with some confidence and deliver the
results last week no one in the labor
party thinks we're the complete picture
yet we know there's more to do but look
at that transformation we've been on
since 2019.
well I I don't agree with that because I
think if you look at the key
Battlegrounds where there was a labor
and conservative head-to-head in local
elections will also have Independence
and greens and liberals with a much
higher vulture if you look at those
head-to-head places whether it's the red
wall where we lost for the first time
last time or key battlegrounds swing
seats or places we've never won before
in every single one of those we beat the
conservative parties this morning aren't
you I better let you go it's good to see
you as always thanks very much indeed